recordando los horrores de un día
traumático que quedará grabado para
siempre en su memoria
el 9 de enero de 2015 rudy estaba entre
las 20 personas tomadas como rehenes por
américo olivari dentro de un
supermercado kosher parisino
escuchaba una explosión y disparos
quizás hubo dos o tres cuando me di la
vuelta vi a cooley valley disparándole a
todo el mundo llevaba un traje camuflado
y tenía dos ak-47
junto con varios otros
haddad encontró refugio en una cámara
frigorífica en el sótano del
supermercado donde se resguardaron
durante cuatro horas una pesadilla
vivida que jada todavía tiene problemas
para expresar con palabras
todos pensamos que íbamos a morir
alrededor de las cinco de la tarde
policías fuertemente armados irrumpieron
en el supermercado mataron a cooley
valley y liberaron a los rehenes
vinieron a buscarnos con unos 20
policías con máscaras y armas que nos
dijeron que no miráramos que cerráramos
los ojos cuando saliéramos de la tienda
efe
y una zona de guerra sangre por todas
partes no era el mismo lugar
no podemos pasar la página siempre
llevaremos esto con nosotros me dio a mí
mismo como un superviviente
haddad está decidido a contar su
historia de nuevo la próxima vez será
ante el tribunal según dice es una forma
de honrar la memoria de las víctimas